besides you who do you think is the
greatest Jiu Jitsu competitor of all
time
can you make the case for some of them
Marcelo Russia
liangelo I'll have to go with bushesha
because look at the how many titles he
has I mean
he has by far more than Marcelo Marcelo
stopped quite early
leandolo has eight but
sure she's better than him what do you
think makes procession so good
he's a heavyweight that moves like a
lightweight his removes very fast but
he's very agile for his size
so the uh the agility combined with
aggression yeah so it's very hard to
control him because he moves
fast
and he's 112 kilos only 15 sometimes or
110 I'm not sure but he's about around
that so 240 in in pounds so when you
when you agile to 100 to 240 pounds that
makes it very hard to control you what
about making the case for some others
what about the little guys what about
Marcelo if you were to make the case for
him being the strongest what makes
Marcelo good Marcel Garcia is extremely
technical I mean I think he's he's one
of my favorite Juju Safaris
because in in a technical way I think
he's probably one of the best because
raw technique in a bunch of different
positions for submissions he's
he's not very powerful you know
physically he's not very strong
but he can make himself very strong and
his technique is very very high level
have you ever uh trained with him no I
fight him twice yeah
he's more smaller than me it's what
happened in those matches the first
fight I topped him I think five minutes
in which submission choke from the back
color choke from the back
and the second time I beat him by points
but a very large I think 12 to
actually uh
just to continue
uh I wonder if uh if John Donahoe would
agree with you about Mountain back I
can't wait to this is a bear versus lion
conversation but I'm looking there's
there's statistics about
I'm not letting this go uh there's
statistics about
oh look at that Roger what do you know
looking at Hydra Gracie's statistics for
um most successful submissions choke
from the back yeah is the most
because people panic when I'm out ah
they turn the back I choked them out
that's one explanation uh but for people
it is interesting that uh of course this
doesn't capture but this captures a lot
of your major matches
and we should say that you've submitted
most of your opponents so you rarely win
on points usually once submissions
choke from back is most of them then
cross joke from out arm bars a lot too
so 18 from choke from back 12 cost joke
10 armbar
uh five RNC rear naked is for nogi okay
so Ezekiel is very powerful I took I'll
use it's a strong weapon yeah also from
Mount for also from Up
oh that's when you can't get the one
hand in no because the Ezekiel most
times I use against people is is that
is the attack that as soon as I get to
the Mount when they're trying to escape
the open up and I get them it has to be
at that initial
timing so it's not a thing you use to
like bother them in order to create
either I get it right right away or I
don't bother trying much because you
need to keep one hand behind the head
and that um you're naturally on that
position as soon as you mount most of
the times and the moment that you mount
someone no one accepted they go mount it
they're gonna explode to get out so hold
in the head it gives you a better weight
a way to dominate them initially you
know to deal with that explosiveness on
the big on the initial in the beginning
and then but then we have to let go to
try it you're a very limited hold in the
head
in terms of goats uh shanji
I feel like he doesn't get enough credit
that he deserves he had an extremely
dominant performance in competition what
about solo and Sanji hibera what are
your thoughts about what makes them so
good he had a bunch of tough matches
with ashanji yeah and Solomon eight
times
I fought solo once
what uh
I think I'm bringing up a sore Point
um
oh did Sanji tap when you uh or did the
time right now and that uh was the last
time you guys face each other yeah 2008.
that was incredible to watch uh also
uh
I think you pull guard with one minute
left working towards or attacking I mean
it's probably very tough to to get
anything and uh for people who don't
know time ran out you had uh something
that looked like an arm block
and uh shanji
look like he may be tapping but it
looked like he might be just celebrating
which is mostly I'm not sure I'm not
sure it was
I'm not sure because
I think he's I'm just just straight he's
on time finish yeah so I'm not sure if
it was tapping
to you know to let go time time's up or
because of the outside most likely the
time was up yeah and also there's a
thing where you start you realize
there's only three two seconds left used
to kind of start celebrating you realize
that
um hydra's not gonna be able to finish
this arm bar in the time left so you
start celebrating no I think he topped
to say the time the time is up anyway
what do you think like the longevity
especially is impressive with with uh
with shanji how long I think he doesn't
get credit as much as he deserves
because he pushed his career very far
and the last few years he was on his
best
so he's
if you were to stop before you know you
would people would remember him on his
highest
but he kind of pushed
more than his
Peak let's say